cyril payen on a vu une de vos photos
sur sur wagner on en parlera bien sûr
dans votre chronique quel a été le point
de bascule selon vous pourquoi
est-ce-que pas du jour au lendemain au
fond paris et bamako ont divorcé alors
il ya là temporal dans la chronologie la
chose évidente évidemment c'est le
putsch du colonel assimilés aux états
qui a effectué une rupture dans la dans
la dans la confiance et puis surtout le
double poutre puisqu'il a refusé le
gouvernement de transition a repris le
chemin de de l'absence je lirai de
chronogramme électoral si et commencer à
envenimer les choses mais ça c'est sûr
j'irai c'est sûr le sur la sur la forme
sur le fond et ça l'avenir nous le dira
et l'histoire retiendra certainement
cela c'est aussi une sont blâmés l'état
major français c'est aussi qu'on a
engagés certainement une guerre on le
rappeler parfaitement dans ce sujet en
2013 on nous on ouvre une guerre on
commence une guerre mais il faut savoir
évidemment la terminer et on voyait bien
que même au sein de l'état major
français l'opération serval qui était
rapidement devenue barkan et qui
essayait de se redéfinir en incluant une
force européenne qu'on attend thoune est
toujours à temps et qui n'abîme y
arrivera vraiment jamais c'était qu'on
fait en avait vraiment fait le tour du
cadran ce n'est même pas moi qui le dit
c'est est l'ancien chef d'état major des
armées le général de cointrin il y avait
des tentatives d'alerter le politique
sur la décision à prendre cette décision
2d de redimensionner cette opération qui
durait trop qui coûtait cher aussi et
bien elle a été actée par le président
macron le 10 juin dernier c'est sans
doute ce qu'on retiendra c'est que
c'était déjà trop tard puisqu'il y avait
ces difficultés avec bamako et puis le
fait que 23 mille cinq cents personnes
du civil depuis 2015 entre le burkina
faso le niger le mali se soucier des
personnes cilic ont été tués dont plus
de 10000 au mali sa puce créer un dhimmi
tab le mans un épuisement une
exaspération de la part d'une population
qui voyait un déferlement technologie de
barkan et qui ne voyaient pas
effectivement une sécurité partout
revenir donc je dirais il ya beaucoup
d'explications c en est un peu à chaud
aujourd'hui mais il ya pas mal
d'explications pour tenter de dorel de
répondre à votre question est ce que la
france
a manqué de boussole de stratégie on
voyait bien l'objectif final en 2013
c'est est de protéger bamako des
djihadistes les repousser et au fil du
temps l'ennemi est devenu un peu
invisible encore une fois aussi sait
aussi où on est dans une guerre
informationnelle on ne commence à
apprendre de nos erreurs c'est ce qu'on
disait il ya quelques instants avec le
porte-parole de l'armée française que
nous avons eues en exclusivité pour rfi
et france 24 il reconnaît que la guerre
informationnelle la guerre de
communication c'est à dire de donner des
résultats plus qu il y a eu sur le fait
sur le sur le terrain des résultats 1,18
à blement de tuer des têtes d'affiché du
gcim ou du gym donc le groupe et les
affidés d'al qaïda ou du coop et
islamique c'est bien mais avec des
techniques de guérilla dans un pays
aussi immense que le mali dans un dans
une une superficie de 5 5 millions de
kilomètres carrés qu'est le sel avec
quelques milliers d'hommes ce n'est pas
assez il y avait certainement une erreur
de communication de plus parler des
faits c'est pour ça que les éléments
dans cette guerre informationnelle
d'ailleurs dans laquelle les russes
évidemment ils sont très forts ils ont
beaucoup beaucoup plus on le voit sur
l'ukraine beaucoup plus d' avance que
certaines que certaines nations
occidentales ont marqué beaucoup de
points comme on trafique d'ailleurs en
s'engageant dans et bien l'utilisation
de réseaux sociaux manipulation de foule
de l'opinion en mettant comme tout le
responsable bouc émissaire l'armée
française et la france mais ce qui est
ce qui restera certainement et on le
sait bien on le sent bien avec les
hommes engagent les éléments de langage
du président au maquereau qui lui-même a
hérité de cette guerre après tout ne
s'est pas lui qui l'a initié il devait
l'arrêter c'est le fait qu'on a pas su
arrêter cette guerre et que ce n'est pas
nécessairement un échec militaire mais
alors oui peut-être un échec
diplomatique et politique vous évoquez
les miliciens wagner emmanuel macron a
confirmé leur présence au mali ce matin
elle dit qu'il serve les intérêts des
russes et les intérêts de la junte ils
ne se battent donc pas contre les
djihadistes ça aussi c'est fait ça fait
partie de cette guerre informationnelle
nous avons posé la question à l'état
major français à chaud il y à quelques
instants y at il des preuves tangibles
de présence d'éléments de wagner ou en
nombre aussi important qu'en soit rats
fric la réponse est on ne peut pas
donner des éléments de réponse qui
appartiennent aux services de
renseignements personnellement ça fait
trois fois que j'y vais en moins de deux
mois au mali non en enquêtant sur ce
dossier il est très difficile de
comprendre qui était à la manoeuvre qui
sont réellement ces gens sur ces photos
ça c'est dans une base du centre du du
mali on est dans une guerre
informationnelle ce qui est assez parce
que les russes eux disent clairement on
a pas d'unité régulière envoyé au mali
absolument absolument avec des
contradictions dans le discours de
vladimir poutine ça n'a échappé à
personne lors d'un face à face avec
emmanuel macron où il semble qu eva
nolin kron a été très très militant soit
ils arrivent revenu à la charge
plusieurs fois sur cette question le
laquelle la force la force de cette
guerre informationnelle de la russie
c'est de ne pas avoir à démentir ou 2 ou
2 ou 2 ou de confirmer puisque le mal
est fait le ce que beaucoup d'experts en
sécurité penser qu'il y à quelques
coopérants de wagner en quelques
dizaines pas un millier commandes les
éléments de langage de ces entendre mais
ça suffit à ce que l'ensemble des gens
au mali où l'ensemble du sahel où les
forces occidentales bien il serait une
sorte de simples de ça deux symboles de
fantasmes sur la présence de ces
paramilitaires mais que au front ou pas
puisqu'on parle aussi dans cette guerre
informationnelle de front notamment dans
le centre où les femmes à les forces
maliennes sont au coude à coude avec les
forces russes ça ce sont les éléments de
langage qu'on peut entendre à bamako
dans les manifestations anti françaises
et bien que ces forces si elles existent
sont des coopérants naturel et et
conventionnelles a envoyé par par moscou
que je rappelle que la coopération
militaire entre bamako et et moscou ciel
c'est un peu augmenté ces derniers mois
elle est très ancienne aussi - enseigne
que la france mes anciennes donc tout
cela encore une fois est un jeu de dupes
il ya beaucoup d'éléments de langage de
part et d'autre la seule vérité c'est
que les français vont se désengager sans
doute beaucoup moins rapidement que le
laisse entendre le message présidentiel
ima six mois ça paraît vraiment très
très très ambitieux non je suis paré
tout ceci vous à douzat de 6 à 12 mois
alors il ya les la campagne électorale
française il ya l'objectif peut-être de
faire défiler des soldats français pour
le 14 juillet peut-être que ça dans la
tête d'un président ça peut ça peut
apparaître mais ça paraît très
concrètement pour ne parler que de gao
gao est une est une vraie ville garnison
il encore des bases militaires qui sont
aussi ménaka et gao donc l'idée est de
ramener graduellement vers gao c'est de
ces deux bases mais selon parle de
milliers de gens une logistique
extraordinaire avec des difficultés sur
le terrain puisque on sait que les
convois ont été des convois terrestres
ont été attaqués donc on tout cela
paraisse est peu réaliste mais encore
une fois année les éléments de langage
pour se sortir de ce qui est tout de
même et qui restera je le pense dans
l'histoire comme un piège dans lesquels
les français pour répondre à votre
question votre première question se sont
laissés se sont laissés faire piéger en
fait parce que il y a eu sans doute une
lenteur d'action politique pour donner
une bonne direction à l'action militaire